hey guys I'm Ryan right so today I'm
going to be checking out a trailer for a
film I'm very excited to watch the big
short this film has a lot of [ __ ]
people in it there's Brad Pitt Christian
Bale MAME Ryan Gosling to see you know a
long time ago when I first started
getting into rap I posted a love song to
Ryan Gosling it's called dear Ryan
there's a link in the description box
for you to check it out
it also has selena gomez Marisa Tomei
Steve Carell Melissa Leo and most
importantly it has the guy who played
ryu in street fighter the one with
jean-claude Van Damme Dame oh let's
check this out it's Adam McKay wrote and
directed it I'm really interested to see
the tone and style of this film because
you know he's known for doing a lot of
comedy out here this is a drama so I'm
sure there'd be like humor to the
characters but I'm still really
intrigued let's do this Mike song yeah
Michael
the whole housing market is propped up
on these bad loans they will fail the
housing market is rock solid that's a
time off so Mike burry who gets his hair
cut Supercuts and doesn't wear shoes
knows more than Alan Greenspan yes he
does Niska walks into my office inside
there's some shady stuff going down
while banks we're having a big old party
a few outsiders saw where no one else
could economy might collapse
I'm sure the world's banks have more
than essentials agreed no one's paying
attention the bank's got greedy and we
can profit off of their stupidity you
want to put against the banks to think
we either high or having a stroke kind
of really broad has never ever worked
eventually things go south when the hell
did we forget all that
how can the banks let this end up it's
fueled by stupidity but that's not
stupidity that's full tell me the
difference between stupid and illegal
and my wife's brother arrested yes this
movie looks so cool you just bet against
the American economy the banks and
defraud the American people
now we can kick away the team okay here
we go
we target strippers it's bad loans I'm
an all-cash red Oh not going to be able
to finance on all my loans
what do you mean all your loan nice five
houses in the condo
dopes that's just a [ __ ] cast where
you're like I gotta watch it my my
favorite thing I gather from the trailer
was you got this huge cast assemble but
it looks like each actor really has
their own defined character it's not
like Ocean's eleven - cool movie and all
but you essentially got George Clooney
being George Clooney Brad Pitt being
Brett you know what I mean in this movie
you got all kinds of different
characters and personalities they know
they got character actors and they're
allowing their character actors to
really be characters like everyone looks
great in the film there's that whole
[ __ ] cast I like how there's a lot of
like collaboration and fun facts just
from seeing the cast and like the
filmmakers and the author like the
author of Moneyball Brad Pitt started
Moneyball Christian Bale he's working on
Melissa Leo before and Marisa Tomei same
thing with Steve Carell he's worked with
Ryan Gosling before and Marisa Tomei
because of Crazy Stupid Love and Steve
Carell has also been directed by Adam
McKay and the anchorman films and he
wasn't in the trailer but let's not
forget byron man who played ryu is also
in this film so you got to watch it i
like these movies of like these Wall
Street kind of films I want to see this
film you know like we went through that
global economic meltdown and America
still has a shitty economy and stuff so
I want to see that movie where they're
like people really making millions off
of that and Adam McKay has explored
those topics sort of before you know one
like random comedy bits or helping out
with a story like the other guys or
something but this film does have that
flare that wolf of wallstreet vibe to it
but I feel like there's gonna be a lot
more comedy infused because it's Adam
McKay but I don't feel like the comedies
gonna be like over-the-top or
distracting I feel like it's really
gonna blend in well with the characters
and Ryan Gosling dude it doesn't matter
how much you change your hair I still
want to put my penis in your bum hole
just sayin just sayin anyway guys thanks
for tuning in to the channel that movie
looks [ __ ] great if you're new to it
you can subscribe to the real rejects
you could follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter vine and periscope I
was recently on the jab eco a channel
that's my broseph in the description box
there's a link to the video recently did
it you should check it out I feel like I
could
movie side a little bit more - last but
not least let's do a shout out since uh
barians of RM
orion open a constant viewer your
channel since the hordes in that trailer
and afterwards always come back daily
seeing what's new you're [ __ ] rad and
open city of jokes for a bit now and i
know your own you california um possibly
not stalking you maybe LOL still some
man well dude it's it's really good to
know that you've been a follower ever
since but don't steal my jokes don't
don't steal my jokes you still might
show that you're [ __ ] my mate
you want to steal my jokes yeah yeah
dumb son of a [ __ ] show gotta take you
by the hand and smack you you're a dumb
son of a [ __ ] you tell me that you take
my jokes well [ __ ] you you become a
clown huh
think I'm a [ __ ] clown running out of
I don't know why I went with old school
New York actors to do this shout out for
you but there you go it's your shoutout